Desde la madrugada de este jueves inició
un fuerte operativo de fuerzas federales
comandadas por el ejército mexicano y la
fuerza aérea en el Estado de Sinaloa
concretamente en la capital en Culiacán
operativo que ha dado como resultado de
acuerdo con Fuentes federales la captura
de Ovidio Guzmán hijo de Joaquín El
Chapo Guzmán este sujeto apodado el
ratón hay que recordar ya había sido
capturado en octubre de 2019 pero tuvo
que ser liberado en aquella ocasión por
el riesgo que corría la población dada
la represalias de este grupo criminal en
esta ocasión la fuerza aérea utilizó
Incluso un helicóptero artillado que
disparó metralleta en este operativo
para capturar a Ovidio que es
considerado junto con sus hermanos el
líder del Cártel de Sinaloa y este
operativo hay que señalarlo se da a sólo
unos días de que llega a México Joe
biden presidente de los Estados Unidos
país que reclama en extradición a Ovidio
por enfrentar distintos cargos
relacionados con el narcotráfico desde
de este operativo se han desatado
balaceras y bloqueos por parte del
crimen organizado que ha atravesado
camiones y los ha incendiado en
distintos accesos a la ciudad Asimismo
el aeropuerto ha sido cerrado a las
operaciones las líneas aéreas
comerciales han suspendido los vuelos y
el gobernador del estado Rubén Rocha ha
llamado a la población a mantenerse a
salvo a mantenerse en casa a no salir a
las calles las clases han sido
suspendidas las labores en las oficinas
de gobierno también se cancelaron y la
Embajada de Estados Unidos alerta a sus
ciudadanos a mantenerse informados y
evitar zonas que en las que pudieran
estar en peligro y recuerda que el
Estado de Sinaloa tiene una alerta de
viaje precisamente por el peligro que se